yeah what up my nip slips - pre-order
back a few days ago I play big rigs
which is famous for being the best game
ever but if we have a new challenger
this one is called traffic Miami 3 I
don't know what happened to the first
two
that's world world one and World War two
pretty much happened that's what okay
it doesn't need any further introduction
let's just play Miami traffic three it's
made in paint I think and it's supposed
to be a GTA clone it took me a while to
realize but this is actually the menu
what am i doing
my arms are six what happened okay so I
mashita know what happened that guy what
is he doing hey sir how you doing trying
to switch a gun there we go nade donate
oh [ __ ] rod rod cool guys - [ __ ]
alright let's check out the let's check
out the beach there's this random shark
lying dead here cool best game ever
let's get girl blow him up cool guys
don't look like [ __ ] that shark looks
[ __ ] happy as hell holy [ __ ] I've
never seen a shark so happy to be on
dying you died can I ride the cars no
come on come on let me ride you you
piece of [ __ ] god damn it why am i a she
died anyway alright because I'm goddamn
badass that's why drop them knees
there's cats after me you [ __ ] racist
I'll drop all my babes drop all my biamp
god this is like the greatest game ever
made holy [ __ ] what that walking
animation though okay this is my crib
welcome to my crib goddamn nice
bad TV though I have a table other some
marijuana is that a knife what are you
doing cheetah
you can't cut people you could hurt
someone don't do drugs
hey yo they look at me look at me look
at me what I'm talking to you what he's
shooting back what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you what it just became dark
what the [ __ ] what is that guy doing
walking on what Jesus Jesus is that you
there has to be a way to end their cars
Suzie Madison oh [ __ ]
dead Kevin let's go in a car again
I don't know how to enter never get back
come on he walked in front of me
literally okay let's jump whoa probably
[ __ ] you see that
how does he walk into water not too good
what what am i doing this is not how you
swim man oh it is okay of course
[Laughter]
what am i doing up here stop stop stop
don't make my boy man the graphics are
almost better than minecraft well what
is that a flying man ignore em I don't
understand there we go hell yeah [ __ ]
this is seriously the best game I have
what whoa [ __ ] what happened I want that
car I want it that shut up I can't even
drive it what what what what mine got
can I Drive please please oh god what
the [ __ ] is happening how is this
forward how is this forward someone tell
me how is this forward why are you going
why the [ __ ] are you going oh [ __ ]
direction
[Music]
don't make me fire starter [ __ ] the
poopoo can I take their car holy [ __ ] I
can this is the best game ever
gosh goddamn it sorry about your friend
oops okay got got got whoa what of
course of course don't question it just
keep rolling with it
hey guys what is happening here oh come
on come on
I barely touched him stop your car is
[ __ ] my car it's really awkward it's
nothing I can do with them I can't even
blow them up where the hell are they
okay come here eat this Oh goddamn it
God god damn it Oh missed by a little
bit what why does it it went through in
oh god damn it
whoa what is this whoa oh I blew up
something okay what is this of course it
crashed
why wouldn't it uh what what what is
happening what is happening what what
but where's I guess I'm not the only one
I can't control him what is happening
scared the [ __ ] out of a what's going on
holy [ __ ] this game was the best Oh God
oh I can't do more games feel like this
I'm serious where is that thing we need
to find it again
what okay I he said he is here who he
should just be who I can't coach this is
a cutscene where am I
yeah okay all right that's enough
finally getting fun to play like I've
enjoyed watching
it's a sky company keep sending these
[ __ ] up games I really like it
sound breath nearly this is where my
brain has gone with all the photos like
I haven't checked up any I got Janek I
need help